ouais vous remercier madame la ministre
sur garde des sceaux d'avoir accepté de
devenir cet après midi devant la
commission sur un sujet particulier qui
est celui de la numérisation de la
justice c'est effectivement pour nous un
point extrêmement important qui sans
doute ne fait pas la une de tous les
journaux mais ce n'est pas l'objectif
mais en revanche créer des conditions de
travail de nos magistrats de greffiers
de nos policiers enfin de ceux qui
collaborent 11 et des avocats et tous
ceux qui collaborent à l'oeuvre de
justice
difficile parfois compliqué parfois
incompréhensibles en tous les cas
traduisent d'abord une difficulté
technique majeur et puis finalement une
perte de temps importante dans le
travail qui est à faire et au lieu de
simplifier les choses et c'est plutôt
complexifier je ne veux pas être dans ce
propos introductif mais peut-être vous
donner quelques éléments qui vous
paraîtront peut-être un peu pessimiste
mais en tous les cas c'est pour
compliquer le débat de vérité je sais
que vous avez travaillé sur le sujet que
vous avancez j'ai pas de doute mais
quelques éléments de contexte et crédits
de paiement dédié à l'informatique du
ministère s'élève en 2021 à 267 millions
d'euros contre 242 millions d'euros en
2020 c'est donc une augmentation très
nette de 10 % tous les cas c'est à
périmètre constant
c'est l'analyse qu'en fait la commission
outre 50 emplois créés au secrétariat
général du ministère 206 me a river 206
millions d'euros de crédits de paiement
sont prévues en 2021
on profite du plan de transformation
numérique 2018-2022 contre 177 millions
d'euros en 2020 là encore c'est un
progrès incontestable lors de votre
audition monsieur le garde des sceaux
vous aviez précisé que 353 millions
d'euros de crédits de paiement auront
été dépensés à la fin de l'année
courante 2021 sur les 530 millions
d'euros
dans ce plan d'une durée de cinq ans et
qui doit s'achever
en 2022 est doté pour autant la crise
sanitaire et la commission des lois
comme d'autres mais singulièrement la
commission des lois a mis en lumière
quelques dysfonctionnements structurels
dont souffrent nos juridictions en
matière numérique qu'il s'agisse à la
fois d'équipements bureautiques ou
surtout finalement de solutions
logicielles qui pour partie d'entre eux
sont dépassés nous avons constaté ce
décalage naturellement dans les visites
territoriale où nous sommes allés dans
les différents tribunaux les relations
avec les magistrats avec les greffiers
nous ont montré des difficultés réelles
concrètes pratiques et est donc été
alertée comme beaucoup d'autres dans
tous les cas nous nous sommes nous mêmes
interrogée et surtout en constater
l'urgence qu'il y avait à faire avancer
ce sujet je voudrais rappeler par
exemple un exemple on dirait qu'ils
aient choisir évidemment c'est tribunal
judiciaire de lyon vous prie de m'en
excuser
mais malgré tout en mars dernier lorsque
nous lui sommes allés les greffiers nous
ont alertés par exemple on donne un
exemple
certains nous ont alertés sur les
conditions de mise en oeuvre de la
réforme de l'intermédiation financière
des pensions alimentaires qui nécessite
la transmission d'informations entre les
juridictions et les caisses
d'allocations familiales et bien les caf
dispose d'un outil informatique est
assez performant mais il ne communique
pas avec notre logiciel quand je dis
notre logiciel c'est le logiciel ou une
cité j et les greffiers doivent ainsi
ressaisir
toutes les informations permettant
d'assurer l'intermédiation financière
c'est un exemple il y en ad'autres
matière pénale il ya d'autres cieux
cette nature bon et c'est dans ces
conditions là que nous avons souhaité
même la ministre monsieur le ministre
vous entendre cet après midi car vous
nous avez annoncé un plan d'action avec
la commission des lois souhaitent être
informés de ce plan d'action est de
connaître les moyens que vous aurez mis
en place et les mesures engagées pour
naturellement améliorer la situation je
ne ferai pas l'affront mais je le dis
quand même un peu pour que une fois de
plus mon propos ne veux pas être
désagréable vraiment c'est un souci
important pour nous les juridictions
commerciales ou l'éjection
administrative lactation plus petites
sommes tous d'accord là dessus ils sont
devenus très performant et et on sent
cette difficulté dans les juridictions
d'instruction judiciaire est
véritablement monsieur le garde mam la
ministre il faut qu'on progresse
collectivement sur ce point c'est un
service qu'on rend à nos magistrats ados
greffiers avocats nos policiers et
surtout notre population
voilà ce que je voulais simplement vous
dire ce n'est pas ni un cri d'alarmé ni
ni à un désespoir que j'aime ou presque
naturellement mais c'est une volonté
politique de la commission sur ce
point-là de contribuer à des avancées
significatives à la mam le ministre ne
se garde des sceaux leur a sans doute
des questions qui viendront au cours de
nos débats en avoir quelques-unes
notamment sur l'organisation au sein du
ministère pour piloter cette
numérisation de notre justice en tout
cas non pas qu'elles ne soient pas mais
les améliorations que vous souhaitez
bien sûr c'est aussi des questions comme
la signature électronique des actes en
matière civile que plus loin et pénale
des choses en fait en réalité assez
concrète
franck le mieux c'est de vous laisser la
parole mann avait rien peut-être tous
étiez intervenir avant comme vous voulez
donc moi je propose qu'on laisse la
parole même l'ami c'est monsieur le
garde des sceaux puis vous avez rien
vous bien pousser le président à la
merci merci monsieur le président et le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs ni cri d'alarmé cri de
désespoir et vous avez raison de le
pousser ni l'un ni l'autre monsieur
présidente parce que
nous sommes en train de progresser nous
avançons à grands pas et je le dis
immédiatement et d'emblée c'est une
volonté farouche pour moi de faire
avancer le numérique
vous l'avez dit c'est un outil essentiel
pour les magistrats pour les greffiers
pour les avocats pour les huissiers
aussi une rose en pour l'euro mais mais
pour le justiciable donc le justiciable
peut remplir par le truchement du
numérique
son dossier date juridictionnelle
quand il peut avoir accès aux
différentes étapes de la procédure
civile c'est pour le justiciable quelque
chose d'absolument essentiel
je voudrais d'abord vous remercier
monsieur le président pour
l'organisation de cette audition en
compagnie de ma collègue madame amélie
de montchalin cette audition s'inscrit
bien sûr dans une logique d'information
du parlement qui a été la mienne dès le
vote du budget 2021 et au regard de
l'importance des enjeux de la
transformation numérique de la justice
j'ai mis en place de façon informelle
un rendez-vous bi-annuel de suivi de la
transformation nomine numérique du monde
ministère entend d'une part les
rapporteurs budgétaire de la mission
justice des commissions des finances et
des lois du sénat et de l'assemblée
nationale et d'autre part les services
du ministre de la justice
spécifiquement en charge de ces
questions et la première édition de ce
format s'est d'ailleurs tenue le 5
février dernier lorsque j'ai pris mes
fonctions en juillet de l'année dernière
nous sortions d'un premier confinement
qui avait fortement affecté le ministère
de la justice
les défis à relever et être de taille
avant même d'engager les grandes
réformes que je porte aujourd'hui devant
vous j'ai bien sûr constaté
l'investissement des services et des
agents pour relever les défis de cette
crise et je veux ici saluer les efforts
considérables de tous les professionnels
tous les professionnels de la justice
pour se relever et déployer les moyens
numériques qui permettent à
l'institution judiciaire et qui a permis
à l'institution judiciaire de
fonctionner durant cette période grâce à
ces efforts je le dis toutes les
missions de la justice ont pu être
maintenues à l'occasion du choc au cou
[Musique]
l'engagement de la chancellerie dans sa
transformation numérique était totale
j'en veux pour preuve mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs l'investissement
budgétaires réalisées chaque année en la
matière avec une ambition portée à vous
l'avez rappelé monsieur le président 200
tentes aux deux millions d'euros pour
on va le dire c'est un effort sans
précédent en matière numérique pour la
justice et ce sans même parler du plan
de relance
je souhaite vous exposer les trois
grandes orientations je porte pour une
numérisation réussi de l'administration
de la justice
premièrement nous avons d'abord réalisé
un effort inédit de mise à niveau des
équipements du ministère la
modernisation des infrastructures du
ministère nous est apparu indispensable
bien sûr pour améliorer la qualité la
fiabilité des services numériques
existants la crise sanitaire a fortement
accéléré ses travaux et j'entends bien
sûr poursuivre cet effort en 2021 et en
2022 et pour cela j'ai obtenu un
financement à hauteur de 5 millions
d'euros au titre du plan de relance
face à cette crise la première urgence
devenir la toute première urgence était
d'augmenter massivement les capacités de
connexion aux réseaux du ministère de la
justice
en quelques semaines elle est passé de
2000 accès simultanés à plus de 30000
les sites équipés en fibre optique sont
passés de 198 en 2017 à 979 en 2021
une augmentation significative de la
dotation en équipement a été réalisée
ces derniers mois nous sommes passés de
7500 ordinateurs portables en 2010 est à
44 milles en juin 2021 100% des
magistrats sont équipés 39 5% des
fonctionnaires de greffe et 41 % pour
les autres fonctions et prochainement
six mille ordinateurs portables seront
distribués prioritairement bien sûr au
greffe s'agissant de l'accès aux
applicatifs métiers et convient de
préciser que les trois applications
essentielles pour la justice pénale
cassiopée api et le casier judiciaire
sont désormais accessibles à tous et à
distance les applicatifs nécessaires au
traitement à distance des contentieux
civils sont également ouverts et je peux
annoncer que depuis mai 2021 100% des
juridictions civiles ont un accès en
ligne alors logiciel métier
nous avons aussi continué à travailler
pour rendre accessibles à distance de
nouveaux applicatifs en particulier ceux
des cours d'appel et des juges pour
enfants statuant tu en assistance
éducative
une expérimentation est actuellement en
cours allait les mener à metz avec de
premiers résultats qui sont
particulièrement encourageants par
ailleurs le ministère travaille au
déploiement d autres jouty numérique au
profit de tous les utilisateurs
premièrement la visioconférence avec
près de 2500 visioconférence déployés
deuxièmement la communication
électronique avec les partenaires en
2021 sachez qu'une convention nationale
vient généralisée simplifier la
communication électronique pénale entre
les juridictions et les barreaux je
pense en particulier à l'outil plex qui
permet la communication électronique de
procédure avec les avocats avec l'envoi
des maths dématérialisée de près de
400000 procédure l'an passé nous devons
avoir monsieur le président un souvenir
commun c'est l'époque de la photocopie
des dossiers 3 francs la page il fallait
six mois pour obtenir une copie du
dossier
ça se fait maintenant en un clic est ce
un outil facilitant la communication
bien sûr avec les huissiers dont j'ai
parlé tout à l'heure un instant et cet
outil est également en cours
d'expérimentation
troisièmement des bornes wifi ont été
déployés passant de 433 en 2017 à 4200
en 2021
quatrièmement mes équipes ont travaillé
afin de disposer d'une signature
électronique équivalente à la signature
manuscrite papiers ayant la même force
probante pour pouvoir dématérialiser les
dossiers de procédures
les premiers déploiements réalisés avec
succès ont d'abord eu lieu sur la
procédure pénale numérique sur les 24
sites bénéficiant de la numérisation des
procédures correctionnelles la signature
manuscrite est remplacé par la signature
électronique pour tous les actes qui
sont établis et enfin récemment à paris
le jugement relatif à la sphère du
médiator ainsi étaient signés
électroniquement pour faciliter son
envoi électronique à des milliers de
parties civiles
deuxièmement j'ai j'ai souhaité ensuite
fixer un cap très clair recentrer les
trajectoires des grands projets
numériques sur la justice du quotidien
avec un bénéfice immédiat pour le
justiciable les réformes législatives
l'émergence de nouveaux projets la crise
sanitaire les difficultés inhérentes à
tout projet informatique ans pour partie
bouleversé le déroulement du plan décidé
en 2010 est actuellement les moyens
donnés à savoir 260 emplois dédiés au
plan de transformation numérique et un
budget d'investissements de 530 millions
d'euros sur cinq ans sont affectés à
plus d'une centaine de projets d'ampleur
très diverses pour y mettre bon ordre
j'ai souhaité prioriser 12 projets afin
de placer au coeur de notre stratégie
numérique le bénéfice immédiat pour le
justiciable
je pense par exemple à la
dématérialisation de la procédure pénale
plus connu sous le nom de programme ppn
la dématérialisation de l'aide
juridictionnelle
le logiciel parcours à disposition des
éducateurs de la pjj pour mettre en
oeuvre le nouveau code de de justice
pénale des mineurs
la justice civile numérique la
dématérialisation de la gestion du tige
je vais m'arrêter un instant sur le
programme ppn la procédure pénale peut
être entièrement numérique de boutons
beau c'est à dire depuis la plainte de
la victime jusqu'au jugement
un gain de temps et d'efforts pour tous
les professionnels du droit notamment
pour les avocats qui peuvent disposer
plus rapidement des procédures
nécessaires à la défense des intérêts de
leurs clients
et c'est aussi un net allègement des
formalités qui pèsent au quotidien sur
les policiers les gendarmes qui sont
dispensés désormais d'établir des copies
de leurs procédures s'est également bien
sûr un gain pour les fonctionnaires de
greffe qui assume actuellement des
missions d'archivage de manutention
et de reprographie le ppn s'articule
autour de plusieurs phases
l'automatisation du traitement des
procédures sans poursuites dont toutes
les juridictions métropolitaine d'ici
décembre 2021 pour autorisé
l'enregistrement sans manipulation
humaine de près de deux millions de
procédures par an ainsi que
l'information des victimes des suites
données à leurs plaintes ont
concrètement qu'au fond c'est ça qui
compte
les usagers pourront obtenir en ligne le
résultat du traitement de leur plainte
à ce jour elle a été déployée dans 61
tribus la numérisation des procédures
correctionnelles au sein d'une
quarantaine de juridictions afin d'y
tenir d'ici mars 2022 des audiences
correctionnelles numérique la signature
manuscrite est remplacé par la signature
électronique elle a été déployée dans 24
tribunaux les outre-mer en bénéficiant
évidemment du déploiement de la ppn elle
sera par exemple installé à saint pierre
de la réunion dès cet automne les
services de la ppn seront disponibles
dont toutes les juridictions de france
d'ici décembre
2023 j'ai souhaité mettre en place une
maîtrise des coûts et faire évoluer les
méthodes de travail ses efforts sont
menés de manière coordonnée en lien
étroit avec les services de madame la
ministre
la transformation et la fonction
publique que je veux ici chaleureusement
remerciés pour son aide et ses conseils
précieux les mesures nouvelles de suivi
des projets sont mises en oeuvre avec le
développement d'un outil de comptabilité
analytique et ministère de la justice
s'est rapproché de l'adie num du
ministère de l'intérieur afin de
capitaliser sur de bonnes pratiques en
interministériel avec l'organisation de
revue de projet sur les douze projets
phares du ministère enfin pour mener
cette transformation ministère de la
justice n'a pas hésité à se faire
accompagner
lady avec l'appui de madame la mise de
la transformation public et à ma demande
le premier ministre a accordé un
financement supplémentaire de plus de 53
millions d'euros
d'autre part la collaboration étroite
des services de nos deux ministères nous
permet d'envisager que le ministère de
la justice puisse sur le long terme
assumer ses responsabilités avec ses
propres compétences
en ce qui concerne le pilotage monsieur
le président des chantiers numérique un
pilotage externalisés pour est en
apparence présenter des avantages
avantages de la rapidité de l'agilité
nécessaires à notre transformation
numérique
toutefois et vous le savez bien comme
cela a été rappelé par la cour des
comptes dans son rapport sur les grands
projets numériques de l'état il convient
de garder un bon équilibre
un juste équilibre entre un ter
nalisation externalisation la maîtrise
technologique ne ne suffit pas la
connaissance des métiers est à mon sens
tout aussi essentielle pour réussir
notre transformation numérique et 7 ans
travaillant en proximité avec le terrain
les greffiers les magistrats les
tribunaux les agents de l'administration
pénitentiaire
les professionnels de la protection
judiciaire de la jeunesse que nous
réussirons notre transition numérique je
tiens donc à ce que le ministère
conserve son autonomie numérique
j'ai réalisé 50 recrutements nouveau
sein du secrétariat général pour le
numérique
à cette fin enfin j'ai souhaité
valoriser le respect de trois grands
principes en réaffirmant le rôle clé du
ministère de la justice
à l'ère du numérique la justice est une
institution humaine
sa transformation numérique douati
contribué en la rendant plus accessible
plus lisible pour nos concitoyens ont le
rassurons les mêmes garanties de droit
que la procédure soit numérique ou en
papier
vous le savez la protection des données
est un enjeu majeur pour tous nos
concitoyens je vais y est ce que tous
les traitements de données à caractère
personnel d'un nu à une information et
une voie de recours pour tous nos
concitoyens la mise en oeuvre de l'open
data des décisions de justice est tout
aussi capital le numérique c'est aussi
le moyen de rendre la justice plus
transparents et accessibles dès cet
automne la peine l'open data des
décisions du conseil d'état de la cour
de cassation favorisera l'accès au droit
à terme et au plus tard en 2025 seront
concernés plus de 350 mille décisions
annuelles pour l'heure administratives
et plus de 3,5 millions de décisions
pour l'ordre judiciaire
je veux enfin tout particulièrement à
l'inclusion de tous les citoyens et aux
risques d'exclusion liés à la fracture
numérique
les efforts menés pour l'inclusion des
personnes en situation de handicap
doivent également être menées en matière
numérique et pour cela un audit sur les
démarches en ligne de mon ministère a
été réalisé un travail engagé pour
favoriser leur accessibilité partout sur
le territoire et point justice ont été
intégrés offrant ce service permettant à
chacun de trouver au plus près de chez
lui la pluie dont il a besoin pour ses
démarches numérique puis monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs votre disposition pour
répondre à toutes vos questions précises
et mes propos et si vous me le permettez
je cède immédiatement la parole à ma
collègue
merci monsieur le président est monsieur
le garde cheryl mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs et sénatrices et dames
le rapporteur d'abord vous remercier de
l'opportunité qui nous est donnée
aujourd'hui d'échanger sur un sujet
qui est comme vous l'avez rappelé
monsieur le président au coeur des
préoccupations des français et que je
peux témoigner être au coeur des
préoccupations du gouvernement dans son
ensemble et donc une préoccupation qui
est partagé par votre commission la
transformation numérique des services
publics est une priorité et elle
concerne en premier lieu le service
public de la justice et nous y
travaillons en étroite collaboration
comme l'a rappelé le garde des sceaux
avec une relation comme il l'a dit
chaleureuse précise et sur lesquels vous
allez voir nous sommes en pleine
alignement avec la stratégie numérique
plus générale la transformation public
que je porte c'est un enjeu majeur parce
que derrière le numérique
au fond c'est l'effectivité de l'accès
au droit et de l'accès aux services
publics et donc de l'accès à la justice
qui nous préoccupe aujourd'hui c'est une
conviction que nous partageons avec le
garde des sceaux
car c'est un élément fondamental du
pacte républicain est une condition
essentielle du bon fonctionnement de
l'état de droit et donc cette
transformation tient une place
particulière dont le chantier majeur de
la modernisation de l'administration que
je conduis au sein de ce ministère de la
transformation de la fonction publique
et qui réunit comme vous le savez pour
la première fois dans une même maison
la gestion des ressources humaines les
outils numériques de travail des agents
et donc des usagers et la transformation
des organisations publiques
tout d'abord je tiens à vous dire que
cette numérisation des services publics
est une priorité de la transformation d
administration pour ce quinquennat le
constat est quand même assez simple les
français peuvent faire leurs courses sur
internet payer leur abonnement ligne
préparer leurs vacances de paix chez eux
mais doit vous devez encore trop souvent
réaliser des démarches administratives
en papier ou se déplacer pour aller
déposer un dossier auprès d'un service
public
nous ne pouvons pas nous y résoudre et
nous devons donc faire entrer totalement
de service public au 21e siècle en y
mettant l'énergie la méthode et les
moyens nécessaires
le président réduit vous avez fixé un
cap en 2017
c'est qu'en 2022 l'ensemble des
démarches numérique qui correspondent
aux services publics du quotidien des
français soit accessible en ligne
le garde des sceaux l'a souligné
cette ambition s'est vu réaffirmé par la
crise sanitaire qui est venue renforcer
les attentes de nos concitoyens pour des
services lui de qualité plus proche plus
efficace et cette crise nous a conduits
comme le garde a rappelé également à
accélérer de façon très significative
les chantiers que nous avions engagé
donc le ministère la transformation et
de la fonction publique à la
responsabilité du numérique de l'état
est donc au coeur de cet engagement
ambitieux de numériser tous les services
publics du quotidien et doit s'assurer
de sa déclinaison dans tous les
périmètres ministériels en tant que
ministre je dois donc exercer une
pression amicale sur mes collègues
ministres c'est pas cher eric mais
surtout apporter un réel soutien humains
et financiers pour accompagner les
transformations qui sont
particulièrement lourdes pour les
organisations et je vais revenir pour
que les citoyens les parlementaires
l'ensemble des acteurs puissent suivre
la mise en oeuvre nos engagements
je publie de manière totalement
transparente tous les trimestres un
point d'avancement sur la numérisation
des 250 démarches les plus usuels des
français dans tous les domaines
la dernière publication est en avril la
prochaine aura lieu en juillet et vous
pouvez être certain monsieur le
président que je vous transmettrai une
copie pour que vous voyez les progrès et
la situation alors en termes de progrès
en 2017
63 % seulement des 250 démarche peu dont
nous parlons et est accessible par une
bienne numérique aujourd'hui nous en
sommes à 80 3%
nous visons 100% en 2022 mais il faut
bien avoir en tête que ce qui compte
c'est surtout la qualité et donc
d'ailleurs nous obligeons d'une certaine
manière à ce que l'ensemble de ces
démarches est un bouton qui s'appelle je
donne mon avis pour nous assurer que les
ceux qui pratiquent ces applications
puissent nous dira si les ont trouvés
simple ergonomique et facile à utiliser
aujourd'hui la note donnée par les
français à ses 250 démarche en moyenne
est de 7 3 sur 10 nous pouvons donc
faire mieux et nous rappeler que
aujourd'hui 80% des premiers contacts
entre un usager et l'administration 80%
se fait en ligne sur un site internet un
mail ou une application mobile
je tiens ici néanmoins apporter une
précision l'enjeu n'est pas de tout
passer sur un format numérique et de
passer un formulaire papier à un
formulaire numérique plus
fondamentalement le numérique participe
vraiment à renouveler le rapport condom
concitoyens avec l'administration et
notamment en facilitant le partage de
données garde des sceaux on a parlé
notamment
vous nous avez parlé aussi sur les
enjeux de la caf par exemple et de
l'institution judiciaire
tout ce que nous pouvons faire pour
faciliter cette circulation des données
le pré remplissage des formulaires bien
sûr en respectant pleinement la
protection des données personnelles
nous faisons pour l'aide
juridictionnelle notamment en pré
remplie sans les ressources grâce à des
données déjà connues par l'état jeu
j'aurai le plaisir de revenir ici au
sénat demain dans le cadre du projet de
loi 4d et de pouvoir exposer en plus
grands détails
une disposition qui à ce titre elle nous
aidera à faire circuler ces données de
manière beaucoup plus efficace et donc à
simplifier la vie des usagers
je tiens enfin à suny et que le
numérique doit être un facteur
d'efficacité nos services publics et en
aucun cas se développer au détriment du
maintien d'un accès diversifiée aux
services publics sur tout le territoire
c'est à quel pétrin l'accueil physique
un pont téléphoniques et je sais que
vous êtes en tant que représentant de ce
territoire très attaché le deuxième
point je voulais aborder aujourd'hui
monsieur le président c'est que pour
atteindre ces objectifs très ambitieux
mais réaliste nous avons mis en place
une vraie stratégie de transformation
numérique que j'aurais vous présenter
pour voir comment celles la justice
s'insère dans un cadre plus large je les
présentais le 4 mars dernier
d'abord acquis à qui nous adressons nous
fouillent à trois publics dans l'est le
citoyen et dans le cas présent le
justiciable qui soit une entreprise un
particulier ou une association
et donc c'est d'abord pour eux avant
tout nous travaillons de deuxième public
si l'on peut l'appeler ainsi que pour
lequel nous travaillons c'est l'agent
c'est ces hommes et ces femmes dont j'ai
la charge en tant que mise la fonction
publique qui parfois ont été un peu
délaissé le numérique prenant souvent le
visage de celui de l'usagé beaucoup
moins de celui qui était derrière le
guichet virtuel au réel
trop souvent d'ailleurs les agents ont
vu le numérique comme une contrainte
voire
nas alors que s'il est correctement
déployé si l'accompagnement nécessaire
est prévu et on le voit avec les
greffiers les magistrats tous les agents
qui travaillent au quotidien
cette une réelle bien de productivité de
conditions de travail et d'efficacité
regardez soul a rappelé la première
chose qu'on avait en fait est bien
d'améliorer de l'équipement nous avons
déployé 185 mille ordinateurs portables
dans le champ interministérielle en un
an
entre mars 2020 et 2021 c'est à dire ce
que nous avions prévu de faire en quatre
ans et donc cette accélération
nous devons bien sûr la poursuivre
notamment pour simplifier les procédures
réduire l'usagé papier développer la
signature électronique comme l'a rappelé
le garde déjà dans un stand de domaine
et je sais que vous y travaillez cher
eric avec tout votre ministère et
beaucoup de conviction
et puis troisième public au fond auquel
nous nous adressons ce sont les
partenaires de l'action publique ce sont
ceux qui contribuent aux services
publics parfois on parle d'état
plateforme est donc rappelé que l'accès
au public ce n'est pas que l'état le
service public de la justice dépend de
professions réglementées comme le sont
les avocats les huissiers les notaires
et qui donc doivent pouvoir être
pleinement associés à cette
transformation les trois enjeux
maintenant en termes d'objectifs sont
très simples qualité transparent
souveraineté qualité c'est à dire que
nous devons avoir une expérience
numérique pour les usagers pour les
outils internes des agents qui
permettent de la simplicité de la
protéine productivité et donc un
meilleur service transparence comme l'a
rappelé le garde des sceaux
c'est l'enjeu de l'open data nous avons
souvent une culture administrative trop
vertical trop centré sur l'état
l'ouverture cédant couverture des
données et nous avons avec le premier
ministre
réaffirmé dans l'ensemble des champs
ministériel après un rapport
parlementaire
doerig bothorel en particulier que nous
avions pris la décision d'ouvrir 60
nouveaux jeux de données particulières
demandées en 2021
la carte scolaire des collèges les
fiches les fichiers foncier les
personnes morales les données
d'informations routières en temps réel
évidemment c'est un enjeu important pour
le mystère la justice comme pour tous
les autres ministères et là aussi nous y
travailler
troisième enjeu c'est la souveraineté la
souveraineté c'est à la fois s'assurer
que l'on garde la main sur les solutions
que l'on achète et que l'on développe
aussi garder la main sur nos usages en
matière de données personnelles
le 17 mai dernier avec bruno le maire et
cédric au nous avons présenté la
stratégie d'hébergement et de cloud j'ai
acté que les administrations devaient
mobiliser les technologies d'hébergement
au meilleur niveau technologique mais à
deux conditions extrêmement strictes qui
je crois
seront particulièrement importantes pour
la commission que vous présidez
d'une part une protection de haut niveau
sur les enjeux de cybersécurité et
d'autre part une protection contre
toutes les règles extraterritoriale afin
de s'assurer que les données restent sur
le territoire européen et je pourrai
revenir sur cette stratégie en matière
de cloud évidemment si vous souhaitez
c'est un sujet qui est parti en prégnant
dans la justice car les attentes de nos
concitoyens en matière de protection de
leurs données
son père son personnel sont très
légitimes puisque c'est un domaine
éminemment régalien garder son vous a
dit à quel point effectivement il y
était sensible et attentif troisième
point que je voudrais maintenant détails
et c'est le fait que mon ministère
déploie des moyens inédits en appui de
tous les autres ministères notamment
dans le cas de la relance quand je suis
arrivé en juillet dernier j'ai vraiment
souhaité renforcer les moyens dédiés à
la transformation numérique de l'état
j'ai obtenu une enveloppe dédiée dans le
cadre du plan france relance et donc je
tiens à vous dire que jamais autant de
moyens humains financiers et en méthode
vais revenir n'ont été déployés pour le
numérique de l'état
il ya des moyens budgétaires notamment
les 700 millions d'euros du fonds pour
la transformation de l'action publique
non ce n'est pas le prix dans la
république dès le début du quinquennat
qui a notamment financé miss à la
justice la procédure pénale numérique ou
le système d'information de lagence du
travail d'intérêt général et l'insertion
professionnelle ces crédits c'est aussi
donc un milliard d'euros du plan de
relance destinés à la transformation
numérique les administrations d'état 500
millions sont répartis entre les
mystères 500 millions sont à la main de
mon ministère
répartie avec 208 millions pour facile
et et l'amélioration de la qualité des
outils les agents c'est notamment avec
ces montants que nous avons pu améliorer
le débit du réseau de plus de 800
services et juridictions des miss à la
justice garde des sceaux l'a rappelé
c'est également 200 millions de 104
millions plus précisément d'amélioration
des services pour les usagers
là c'est là que nous numérisons des
démarches par exemple la saisine du
tribunal de proximité pour le
contentieux locatifs et 81 millions
destinés à transformation d'énumérer les
collectivités territoriales et je sais
votre attention sur cette question
derrière les moyennes est aussi une
méthode notamment la méthode du suivi de
nos réformes prioritaires que je réalise
en toute transparence via le baromètre
des résultats l'action publique sur le
site du gouvernement
je remercie le garde des sceaux d'avoir
placé une réforme emblématique de son
action qui est le suivi du travail
d'intérêt général
demain également l'accès à l'aide
juridictionnelle sera sur ce site
internet du gouvernement
disponible dès aujourd'hui vous pouvez
vous y rendre et vous aurez précisément
le nombre de postes de travail d'intérêt
général proposés en tant que peine
département par département pour
transformer la aussi l'ingrédient
essentiel
je crois que c'est très important de le
rappeler ce sont toujours les hommes et
les femmes qui conduisent le changement
sont les agents publics
c'est la raison pour laquelle comme l'a
rappelé garde des sceaux entre
externalisation et internalisation nous
portons une stratégie très ambitieuse de
recrutement des ressources humaines
adaptées que nous cherchons notamment et
j'ai présenté une stratégie pour
l'ensemble de la filière numérique
public le 21 mai dernier en me rendant
d'ailleurs dans une école d'ingénieur
informatique no 4 en jeu c'est
l'attractivité à la fois dame de
recrutement en termes de positionnement
des postes de marque employeur c'est la
diversité notamment la féminisation des
profils que nous recrutons s'assurer que
les modalités de recrutement soit simple
et notamment que nous proposions des
grilles salariales adapté à la
concurrence du marché de l'emploi et du
travail en france et enfin une formation
des agents tout au long de leur carrière
que ce soit dans la filière numérique ou
en dehors enfin mon ministère a un rôle
particulier pour développer les outils
et des services numériques mutualisé
essentiel je vous donne l'exemple de
france connect france connexes et 500
milles qu'ils étaient en 2007 ses 23
millions aujourd'hui france connect
c'est ce qui vous permet aujourd'hui de
récupérer en toute sécurité votre
certificat de vaccination mais c'était
également si vous permet de faire votre
procuration pour les élections et ce
sera évidemment à chaque fois et au plus
vite possible accessibles dans
l'ensemble des démarches numérique
mystère la justice en conclusion je
tiens à vous dire que comme vous l'avez
souligné mesdames et messieurs et madame
la rapporteuse spéciale
je ne vais pas revenir sur l'ensemble
des projets évidemment une miss à la
justice me garde des sceaux a été
extrêmement précis et vous le voyez nous
sommes sur un schéma de développement et
d'avancer qu'il faut que les échéances
dont nous parlons ne sont plus dans sept
ans dans dix ans dans 15 ans elles sont
à 6 mois 9 mois 12 mois notamment c'est
la procédure pénale numérique les deux
jurys sonel ou encore le travail
d'intérêt général
là aussi le garder sur le sel toutes mes
équipes sont en plein soutien
cette accélération qui est portée
assumer et soutenue et donc en
conclusion en un mot peut-être plus
politique le but ce n'est pas d'avoir un
numérique subi d'avoir un numérique
choisit et donc de faire du numérique un
canal d'accès additionnel en complément
des guichets et des autres canaux que
sont le téléphone ou les accueils
physiques
le but n'est pas d'avoir une justice
100% dématérialisé
mais d'offrir à ceux qui le souhaitent
et à ceux qui le peuvent la capacité de
réaliser leurs démarches en ligne
c'est la raison pour laquelle je
soutiens évidemment tout ce qui concourt
à mettre les poings justice au sein des
maisons france et revit ce sont ses 1300
lieu d'accueil en france aujourd'hui
bientôt 2000 qu'en 2022 qui permettent à
chaque français de trouver au même
endroit les uns pour les allocations
familiales pour l'emploi l'assurance
retraite ou encore le ministère la
justice le mystère la justice n'a jamais
eu 2000 points d'accueil grâce à frans
service ce sont deux milieux à moins de
20 minutes de chaque français qui lui
permet d'avoir un accès à un ministère
qui est essentiel on a dit au pacte
républicain et puis dernier point que je
voulais cité c'est que nous avons
annoncées avec le premier ministre le 5
février dernier que nous nous allions au
cours des années 2000 21 nous assurer
que toutes les démarches
je propose un numéro de téléphone de
support quand on est perdu un peu
désorienté au milieu d'une démarche
qu'on puisse avoir quelqu'un en ligne
qui vous accompagnent voilà donc aux
boucles audio
vous voyez la transformation numérique
du miss à la jussie s'inscrit donc dans
l'ambition de transformation de nos
administrations que nous portons
collectivement c'est un sujet qui est
revu chaque trimestre au conseil des
ministres la transformation numérique de
l'ensemble des ministères nous voulons
vraiment concrètement améliorer services
publics du quotidien des français à
renforcer l'efficacité de notre action
publique
le chantier engagé est important mais on
regarde la qualité la coopération entre
mon ministère la chancellerie nous ne
pouvons qu'espérer et même avoir la
ferme conviction que les objectifs fixés
soient atteints dans les meilleures
conditions dans les meilleurs délais là
aussi je vous remercie de votre
attention et celui désormais à votre
entière disposition
merci même la ministre bien joué et et
la parole à madame dominique verreault
rien et puis ensuite monsieur andré
reichardt puis même marie mercier
ensuite madame nathalie goulet puis
notre collecte animal est solide mais
qui est en vision et puis d'autres s'ils
le souhaitent me bonnecarrère
on fera peut-être par paquet pas
capables d'en haut de trois parties
merci monsieur le président donc
inférieures l'emprise merci monsieur le
président merci madame la ministre
monsieur le garde des sceaux comme vous
le disiez
monsieur le président effectivement nous
intéressant de près au fonctionnement de
la justice est assez rapidement lorsque
nous avons regardé des problèmes
budgétaires et que nous sommes d'années
dans les dans les différents tribunaux
le souci informatique est apparu est
évidemment pendant la crise est apparue
encore un petit peu plus fort je dois
vous avouer puisque nous allons
régulièrement dans ces tribunaux et et
moi plus particulièrement à celui
d'auxerre que nous voyons une réelle
progression en termes de matériel c'est
assez clair effectivement ils reçoivent
alors c'est pas aller aussi vite que ce
que ça avait été annoncé d'ailleurs
puisque un moment où 50% des greffiers
étaient censés être équipés ils
n'étaient pas mais on voit que ça arrive
progressivement et même avec une vision
un peu qui a évolué et notamment
aujourd'hui quand un agent reçoit un
ordinateur portable il n'a pas forcément
un ordinateur fixe en plus à côté je
pense que c'est plutôt intelligent et ça
prend en compte la façon dont on
travaille maintenant et à mon avis ça va
permettre de déployer plus rapidement
plus d'ordinateurs a plus d'agents et
donc c'est plutôt une bonne chose donc
côté côté matériel
effectivement ça ça va mais là où ça
pêche toujours et là où nous sommes
le sujet sur lequel nous sommes plus
penché c'est patent encore le
justiciable que réellement l'agent est
donc patent le matériel puisque
effectivement il ça a bien évolué et que
le logiciel est là il est vrai le
président de la cité tout à l'heure nous
étions à lyon et quand on a regardé pour
la réforme de l'intermédiation vous
parliez des changes de de données
là il ya des interfaces à trouver parce
que le greffier de la greffière en
l'occurrence qui qui nous montrait
concrètement comment rentrer un dossier
elle a une famille avec
le père la mère et trois enfants en fait
elle est obligée de tout retaper et pour
chacun pour peu qu'ils aient des
procédures différentes pour les enfants
ou pour la mère elle doit tout retaper
de nouveau sur le deuxième dossier
et en plus si jamais elle s'interrompt
en cours de route elle a peur tout
puisque il n'y a pas de possibilité de
sauvegarde intermédiaire donc c'est
voilà c'est une petite complication
autres autre exemple sur le logiciel au
rebond cassiopée c'est vrai que nous en
avions un peu ri avec son voire perfect
qui est abandonné depuis 30 ans sauf au
ministère de la justice et donc qui met
qui bug encore indépendamment même de
wordperfect et là on a vu une greffière
également essayé de rentrer une peine
avec par exemple la prison ferme plus
sursis plus une obligation de soins on
l'a vu effectivement notez bien
l'ensemble sauf que dans la saisie au
résultat il manque l obligation de soins
et qu'il est donc il a fallu qu'elle
aille bidouiller le système pour pouvoir
obligatoirement m et que ça s'imprime
effectivement donc en fait c'est vrai
que ça prend pas c'est que des petits
embarras mais chaque embarras prenant
dix minutes plus des mines et plus 10
minutes et puis une certaine lassitude
des agents très clairement et on
comprend qu'à la fin de la journée en
fait ils ont juste envie de jeter leurs
ordinateurs
parce que c'est trop compliqué c'est
c'est vraiment ça manque de de
plasticité
et donc voilà est-ce que sur ce sujet là
parce que c'est vraiment des petites
choses mais essentielle à améliorer donc
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui est prévu
j'avais une autre question sur julie par
le qui est abandonnée alors à priori
pour plus de proximité de ce que j'ai
entendu mais aussi peut-être pour des
problèmes techniques
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en dire plus
parce qu'il semble quand même que
c'était attendu par certaines par
certains tribunaux
la signature électronique vous nous avez
répondu 24 tribunaux l'attendent aussi
le point justice et maison france
service
je pense que c'est un projet plus qu'une
réalité aujourd'hui est comment ça va
fonctionner parce qu'aujourd'hui
là pour le coup je peux le voir sur
l'yonne ils n'ont pas un magistrat à
mettre derrière pour pouvoir répondre
aux questions potentiel des différentes
maisons françaises vis qui seront dans
le département et ensuite pour terminer
sur une note positive effectivement nous
étions à la réunion ma collègue agnès
canayer moi même le 5 février où nous
avons pu voir la mise en place des tiges
de la visualisation des tiges et qui
donc là aussi si il y à des avancées on
peut le noter mais par contre ce qui bug
bug toujours donc il ya un vrai travail
merci voilà monsieur richard
merci monsieur le président ma ministre
je garde des sceaux je suis sénateur
alsacien
voilà et à ce titre bien sûr mon
département a les mêmes attentes du
moins je le pense les mêmes attentes que
le reste du territoire français en
matière de numérique naturellement
sauf que chez nous nous avons en plus un
droit local c'est amusant et vous avez
compris que vous connaissez bien sûr on
se le garde des sceaux s'est pas fait
pour spécialement simplifier la
situation et la question je voulais vous
poser concerne précisément les
applications relatives à ce droit local
alsacien mosellan
j'en veux pour preuve vraiment
simplement à titre d'exemple ce qui se
passe avec le registre des associations
d'alsace et de moselle qui différent du
répertoire national des associations de
droit général ce registre des
associations est tenu par voie
électronique
mais contrairement au répertoire
national des associations il n'est pas
accessible par internet pour simplement
une inscription une association ou alors
des modifications d'une association
inscrits est alors en plus il n'est pas
consultable
ces données ne sont pas consultables par
internet non plus alors il nous paraît
naturellement souhaitable que le système
national du répertoire national des des
associations soit étendue aux
associations de droit local
à ma connaissance toutes les questions
de principe et financières sont déjà
tranché donc ma question est très simple
monsieur le garde des sceaux
pourriez-vous simplement examiné cette
affaire et la faire avancer si possible
puisque nous avons le sentiment que dans
l'état actuel des choses ce n'est pas en
bonne voie pour faire très court
une dernière question madame la ministre
chargé de la transformation numérique
vous avez dit tout à l'heure que le taux
de guillemets de satisfaction des
usagers avaient
obtenu enfin était traduisez été traduit
par une note savoir 7,3 sur 10
ce que je peux me faire l'interprète des
2,7 de la note correspondant
naturellement aller à des problèmes qui
nous remontent sinon je vous en parlerai
pas et manifestement il y a encore un
souci en ce qui concerne à
l'accompagnement d'une partie de la
population je ne parle pas du personnel
dont vous avez amplement traiter une
partie de la population qui ne trouve
pas pour trente six mille raisons on
peut parler là de rupture quand vous le
savez fracture numérique etc qui ne
trouvent pas la solution à leurs
sollicitations numérique pour trente six
mille raisons peut-être lié à la culture
à l'âge enfin peu importe mais le souci
existe encore
dominique jullien citer quelques
exemples existent encore à cet égard
donc dès lors que vous aurez quand vous
en avez un tueur helmand l'intention mis
en oeuvre c'est important plan
numérique dans ce pays j'ai bien noté
que vous aviez prévu de ne pas
simplement mettre en place une stratégie
numérique en remplacement de tous les
contacts via notte ce que vous disiez
maintenant la ministre encore de
l'accueil physique encore un numéro de
téléphone dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure qui pourrait c'est certainement
ce qu'il faut faire mais je veux pas du
tout polémique lorsque l'on passe qu'on
m'a dit ça lorsqu'on se branchent sur
par exemple pour simplement on sort de
là on sort de la justice là obtenir un
permis de conduire et que tout en bas il
est indiqué que si c'est pas possible de
le faire par voie numérique il est
possible d'aller en préfecture pour
avoir un accompagnant préfecture qui va
vous aider à
bon la personne qui vend préfecture posé
plusieurs fois la question de savoir où
est le référent enfin bon sens sans
esprit de polémique
donc moi je souhaite simplement
qu'effectivement on prenne en compte
tous ces besoins qui naturellement ne
nous sont relayés vous le disais tout à
l'heure par des élus locaux
c'est bien et si vous mettez en place un
numéro de téléphone support madame la
ministre puis je vous demander d' éviter
de taper à 1 pour taper 2 pour taper 3
pour taper 4 pour oi leur pire encore
latente de cinq minutes sans jamais
avoir de personnes je ne dis pas que ça
se passe mais ça se passe ailleurs
merci merci nous remercier
merci monsieur le président mais c'est
le garde des sceaux j'ai été comme vous
bien évidemment et comme tous
extrêmement catastrophé par par la
sphère de mérignac
cette affaire est très significative
elle est tellement significative qu'une
mission d'inspection a été diligentée
pour essayer de tirer au clair cette
affaire là qui a montré plusieurs
dysfonctionnements dans le transmission
de l'information entre la police et la
justice
en effet ce cette pauvre cette pauvre
femme avait porté plainte
son mari violent était recherché par la
police
et cet individu deux fois a répondu à
des convocations à l'aide de
l'administration pénitentiaire sans être
inquiété est ce que vous pensez me garde
des sceaux que des outils informatiques
plus performants aurait pu éviter ce
drame
ou est ce que vous croyez que le monde
de la justice et celui de la police sont
hermétiques de façon presque
philosophique et quelle évolution vous
prévoyez pour éviter que de telles
défaillances se reproduise pour éviter
de tels drames
monsieur le maire goulet puis ensuite
sur la parole au ministère on
recommencera des questions ensuite oui
monsieur le président manu ministre se
garde des sceaux j'ai une petite série
de questions la première ça fait
longtemps que les juges des tribunaux de
commerce attendent une adresse
justice.fr donc il la réclame il
l'attendît sont sur leur boîte perso
personnel ça pose un certain nombre de
problèmes on en avait parlé lors du
budget est ce que votre ministère avance
sur ce dossier relativement important la
seconde chose c'est que vous avez
évidemment par les souverainetés et vous
avez également parlé de protection la
question que j'aurais vous posez c'est
est-ce que pour pour ces dossiers vous
avez recours à des cabinets privés parce
qu'on a vu récemment notamment le
ministère de la santé avoir recours à
des cabinets extérieurs pour faire ce
type d'évaluation en ce qui concerne la
souveraineté et à la santé notamment en
matière de 2
cloud avait recours à l'expertisé de
cabinets extérieurs
vous avez noté vous aviez engagé une
cinquantaine de personnes sur ces
dossiers au ministère donc vous le
traitez bien en interne j'ai bien
compris
merci de me le confirmer et puis la
deuxième chose c'est est ce que est ce
qui a un impact financier au niveau de
l'ensemble des fichiers est ce qu'il ya
un impact financier des difficultés
liées aux briques site parce que l'année
dernière on l'avait pas mais cette année
on l'a et donc qu'est-ce qu'elle ait des
impacts du bric sites sur tout le
système informatique et numérique du
ministère merci même goût d'écouter la
parole au ministre dans l'ordre qu'il le
souhaite
je garde des sceaux je vais d'abord
commencé une fois n'est pas coutume par
répondre à la dernière question qui
m'est posée j'ai pas entendu dire qu'il
y avait un impact du bric site sur le
développement numérique à la
chancellerie mais pour être tout à fait
complet et ne pas vous frustré je vais
faire regardez cette question de près
j'aurai l'honneur et le plaisir de vous
répondre je n'ai pas entendu parler de
ça y est j'ai la faiblesse de penser que
si tel avait été le cas j'aurais été
informé d'une difficulté d'autant que
j'ai à connaître d'un certain nombre de
difficultés inhérentes à la décision
compris nos amis anglais en particulier
en matière de mandat d'arrêt at elle
également
de procédure civile deux conventions de
la et de mandat d'arrêt européen
donc j'ai à ma connaissance un certain
nombre de questions et celles qui vous
préoccupe on ne fait pas partie des
informations que j'ai reçues mais je
veux quand même être être précis et et
est vérifiée j'ose également répondre à
monsieur le sénateur reichardt donc dont
je sais que vous êtes dation je le sais
d'autant plus que j'avais lu dans un
article de des dna dernières nouvelles
d'alsace que vous même pitié la fin de
la commission ce qui était une erreur si
si c'était une erreur parce que ce n'est
pas moi qui ai g l'article mais je ne je
n'entend pas polémiquer tout le monde
peut se tromper mais moi je n'étais
maintenant mais tout le monde peut se
tromper je n'étais pas à l'origine de
cela j'ai au contraire tout fait pour
restaurer cette commission parce que je
suis attachée au droit local d'alsace
lorraine et j'ai d'ailleurs eu l'honneur
d'aller le dire a strasbourg notamment à
la préfecture j'avais d'ailleurs chargé
madame la préfète du bas-rhin madame
josiane chevalier de piloter un certain
nombre de réunions qui nous permettait
qui devait nous permettre de restaurer
cette commission
si chère au coeur des alsaciens et les
mosellans j'ai reçu dès à présent dans
dés à présent en avril
en avril dernier un rapport il propose
la création d'une commission sous un
nouveau format avec un rattachement
premier ministre et une composition
rénover des attributions une
organisation renforcer les services
monsieur le sénateur travaille
actuellement la rédaction du projet de
décret qui s'inspirera de ses
préconisations et je pense qu'un avant
projet pour pouvoir être circulariser
très très prochainement en tout cas
avant l'été pour être soumis à
l'arbitrage du
du premier ministre mais soyez en
certains cette question nous la
regardons de près au ministère de la
justice parce que nous nous étions
engagés évidemment à redonner vie à
cette commission importante
je suis interrogé bien sûr la sénatrice
ce merci sur les sur les féminicides
vous me posez une question singulière et
infiniment délicate
aurait-on pu éviter peux pas répondre à
cette question dont il est vrai qu'on ne
peut pas réécrire l'histoire
on peut d'autant moins à réussir que ça
nous a pas si ça ne vous a pas échappé
au fond par les temps qui courent on a
une vision fait diversier de la justice
exclusivement fait diversier de la
justice au fond on en demande davantage
au ministre de la justice qu'on pouvait
le faire il ya dix ans il ya 15 ans
puisque on lui demande non seulement de
compter les crimes de les juger bien sûr
mais également de les compter et chaque
fois qu un crime est commis
c'est la fois du ministère en la justice
pour ce mode au jeu caricature mais elle
a naturellement vous le savez des buts
nos politiciens certains s'en sont
emparés vous le savez je je ne m'arrête
pas là dessus
moi je veux quand même vous dire que
nous sommes au rendez vous des efforts
que nous avions promis de faire qu'il
s'agisse des téléphones graves dangers
qu'ils s'agissent des brassées
anti-rapprochement qu'ils s'agissent les
ordonnance d'éloignement
je ne vais pas me donner les chiffres
j'ai donné un coup de patte la fois
dernière en disant mais quand même ces
beaux restes et anti rapprochement ne
peuvent pas rester dans les tiroirs
on en a augmenté l'utilisation de 100%
et dont je me félicite d'avoir fait ça
dans une circulaire comminatoire j'ai
constaté également que des téléphones
grave danger avaient été distribués par
la chancellerie utilisé
sans doute mieux l'utiliser que les
bracelets anti rapprochement parce que
les magistrats se sont davantage emparée
de cet outil les plus anciens faut le
dire on oublie souvent le bracelet anti
rapprochement parfois il n'est pas posée
parce que la victime ne souhaite pas
qu'ils soient posées il faut aussi le
dire ça sont des choses que l'on oublie
parfois et je veux également vous dire
que de la même façon que bien sûr on ne
réécrit pas l'histoire
il ya une plateforme qui est le
réceptacle vous le savez de ces appels
et de ces alertes et les chiffres qui
nous sont données sont très
impressionnants et je pourrais presque
dire ça n'est sans doute pas le cas
parce que par exemple téléphone grave
danger vous avez parfois un coup de
stress de la victime qui ne correspond
pas forcément à une menace mais on évite
beaucoup de crimes beaucoup d'agressions
qui ne feront madame la sénatrice et
vous le savez jamais la une des journaux
jamais et je redis que la chancellerie a
été au rendez vous de ses obligations
ses obligations légitime en distribuant
ces outils dans toutes les juridictions
et en demandant aux juridictions qu'elle
les utilise au mieux et au maximum
maintenant vous avez raison quand on
regarde à notre demande d'ailleurs un
demande du du devise de l'intérieur de
moi-même de marlène schiappa une
inspection conjointe ministère de la
justice ministère de l'intérieur il ya
un certain nombre de dysfonctionnements
dont nous avons demandé pour aller
jusqu'au bout du processus s'il était ou
non constitutif d'une faute
déontologique
nous aurons la réponse à la fin de ce
mois mais pour autant un certain nombre
de dysfonctionnements ont été dès à
présent comment dirais-je mise en
lumière oui il ya des problèmes de
coordination et le ministère de
l'intérieur et le ministère de la
justice conduisent des travaux visant
précisément à améliorer la prise en
charge des victimes notamment pour les
faits de violences conjugales
c'est le mini salle intérieure qui
pilote le dossier
nous avons déjà une plateforme de
signalement qui est qui est disponible
pour les seules violences sexuelles et
sexistes
nous souhaitons élargir cette cette
plateforme et des travaux sont en cours
le portail existant sera rebaptisé p n
avais plateforme national d'aidé aux
victimes et verra son périmètre étendu à
d'autres infractions que celle dont je
viens de vous parler dans le souci qui
est qui est évidemment le vôtre et que
et que et que j'entends est
indispensable que les services se
coordonnent davantage et que on ne
laisse pas passer des informations qui y
sont capitales de là à répondre à votre
question je ne me ne tournerait pas le
faire aurait on pu éviter peut-on éviter
et tout éviter
on essaie bien sûr de faire au mieux
avec ces outils mais vous n'empêcherez
jamais en fous furieux de s'affranchir
et d'une ordonnance d'éloignement et
d'un bracelet et des règles que fixer le
bracelet anti rapprochement ou le le
téléphone garde dont j'ai
malheureusement voilà ce que je peux
répondre sur sûr c'est sur ces questions
je souhaite évidemment répondre aussi
bien sûr un madame à madame la sénatrice
de libériens point justice et 1992 point
justice c'est pas une illusion c'est pas
deux mots et de mots en l'air c'est une
réalité pour moi je suis allé en visite
est intégré au service où effectivement
la ministre shea mais l'équipe
vous l'avez rappelé il ya tout sur place
c'est josien ça s'adresse et c'est ça
qui est beau dans cette dans cette
aventure des points justice à des gens
qui sont défavorisés sont souvent
fragiles
il ya des gens qui sont surinformés
et de leurs droits et et qu'ils se
débrouillent seuls les gens qui ne
peuvent pas le faire et là dans ces
points justice on y retrouve une espèce
de campus dire délocalisation de la
justice de succursales c'est pourquoi on
peut dire mais en tous les cas en iran
la justice et non mais c'est pas ça peut
pas être toute la journée ça peut pas
être un permanent mais il ya un certain
nombre de choses qui sont faites en 1992
je tiens la liste à votre disposition et
est par ailleurs et par ailleurs nous
avons en doublant le nombre de délégués
du procureur permis à des délégués du
procureur d'aller là où les infractions
de basse intensité sont commises et
d'ici quelques jours j'aurai l'honneur
d'ailleurs je l'indiquent d'avoir les
retours de d'expérience de cette justice
de proximité
1c j'ose dire parce qu'il ya un pénale
et deux civils et nous aurons un certain
nombre de chiffres et je pense que ce
sont des chiffres qui vont nous
encourager dans cette voie de la justice
de proximité avec une délinquance de
basse intensité qui n'était plus souvent
traités alors on suit vous m'avez vous
m'avez parlé de deux situations où à
l'évidence ça marchait pas trop bien
bon eh oui le greffier me dites-vous
bidouiller pour faire rentrer je ne sais
plus quoi bien besoin et quand même vous
dire qu'on a mis en place au ministère
de la justice
une veille pour que justement il ya plus
ces bidouillages elle est en place et
les agents greffiers magistrats qui ont
recours aux applis numérique
plutôt que d'essayer de rentrer à toute
force est bidouillée ils appellent ils
ont une réponse
ça répond j'espère non ça répond pas à
votre question est si on a fait ça
exprès justement pour éviter les couacs
alors il ya vous parce que sur une
politique d'ensemble moi je vois bien
vous me citiez deux couacs les une dame
qui a passé entre elles
mais bon je sais pas comment en fait oui
c'est en fait comme c'est en permanence
il s'appelle fort en permanence ils
peuvent pas avoir réellement c il ya des
dysfonctionnements récurrents
oui j'ai d'ailleurs du coup je précise
sur cassiopée qu'on ne pas avoir de
statistiques et que du coup ils prennent
les statistiques de la gendarmerie ou de
la police quand ils en ont besoin et
voilà il ya quand même des
dysfonctionnements récurrents
madame la sénatrice yeux tellement
désolé de vous dire que au soutien des
utilisateurs nous avons mis en place
dans le point d'entrée unique de
déclaration et de suivi des incidents
pour l'ensemble des agents du ministère
donc c'est pour répondre à ces histoires
il ya une difficulté que vous évoquez
c'est vrai c'est le problème entre la
caf
oui en réalité il n'ya pas de lien
direct des changes entre 8,6 et le
portail et le portail de la caisse
nationale et c'est en soi un chouette
sagesse tiens ta l'ampleur du chantier
et des risques inhérents aux transferts
de données mais pour vous rassurer on
travaille très étroitement sur cette
question précise pour régler la
difficulté mais moi je ne souhaite pas
le ce qu'ils nous entendent pense que
ces deux exemples noircissent
l'optimisme qui est le mien et qui n'est
pas un optimisme béat
quant au fonctionnement du numérique
dans notre ministère
parce que je l'aï dit tout à l'heure
c'est pas la méthode cauet nous avons
d'avoir fait des efforts considérables
et que nous avons des choses qui
fonctionnent bien
l'ati gip ça fonctionne bien
ce qui permet aux familles de détenus de
prendre contact avec l'administration
pénitentiaire pour les parloirs
j'ai des retours et des familles et de
l'administration pénitentiaire pour me
dire que c'est fantastique et il ya un
certain nombre de choses dès à présent
je pars reprendre l'ensemble de mon dû
court mais moi je veux bien avec un jour
qu'un jour dans votre territoire un
greffier n'ai pas su rentrer une peine
et vous ai dit mon truc marche pas mon
ordinateur etc
je vous ai d'ailleurs donné les chiffres
des portables que nous avions distribué
oui mais oui d'accord mais d'accord mais
moi pardon non mais non non pouvais pas
me dire paris lyon auxerre qui est un
incident paris un incident à lyon et un
incident auxerre ça ne peut pas ternir
la politique pénale qui est conduite par
le ministère en matière de numérique
parce que c'est pas vrai parce que si on
joue c'est pas un match 2-2 de foot mais
en vain si on joue incidents contre
chose qui fonctionne bien
je vous garantis que le ministère de la
justice bien
présente un score écrasant il ya enfin
moi j'ai tous les jours des magistrats
on y est très attaché la justice de
proximité est quelque chose qui me tient
à coeur et vous le savez j'ai tous les
jours des retours on m'a dit ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne de mieux en
mieux
il ya eu un certain nombre de retards il
ya l'impact de la quotidien certain
nombre de choses qui font que je l' ai
dit tout à l'heure n'est pas caché la
situation mais il ya de vraies
améliorations qui ont été apportées et
surtout de vrais services qui sont
rendus demandé aux avocats par exemple
j'ai cité tout à l'heure si à lyon
auxerre je ne sais plus quelle est la
troisième juridiction vous ne citez là
qu'elle m'a parlé alors non
retrouvez-moi cinq avocats paris qui
vous disent nous on n'a pas les copies
de dossiers dématérialisés
non non mais voilà je viens de temps en
temps si vous voulez on signale ce qui
ne marche pas mais là on est sur quelque
chose de tout à fait factuel et on ne
peut pas donner à ceux qui nous écoutent
en particulier l'idée où l'image qui
serait fausse que le numérique dans la
justice n'a pas considérablement
progressé il n'y a pas de véritables
avancées
j'ai priorisé moi c'est ce que j'ai fait
tout de suite parce que ce qui me tient
à coeur c'est la proximité pour prendre
un certain nombre de thématiques partant
du principe que titre au pétrin mal en
basse on a réduit à douze grands
chantiers pour les mener à leur terme et
madame la ministre vient de rappeler que
c'est pas dans la perspective 2030 c'est
pour certaines d'entre elles dans les
mois qui viennent et pour d'autres dans
un an et demi mais on aura bouclé tout
cela dans l'ailé cassiopée par exemple a
demandé je réponds un peu précisément la
la la la conception de casser alors
autant il ya aucune difficulté en
matière procédure pénale numérique
pourquoi parce que les applications
informatiques de la ppn sont pour
l'instant dédié au stockage des dossiers
en revanche la conception cassiopée rend
très complexe et lourd
l'intégration de réformes législatives
successives pour la mise en oeuvre du
cjp m mes services ont revu toute leur
organisation
le gain il doit être nette par rapport
aux précédentes réformes et pour le long
terme le sud
et c'est moins la refonte de cassiopée
on est au coeur de votre question que
l'évolution de notre doctrine en matière
de trains penser même la sénatrice que
pour les jugements pris sous l' empire
du futur c'est gipn mes services doivent
coder des trams de 160 pages modifiable
à volonté
c'est un travail de fond et qui n'est
pas prévue dans l'actuel plan de
transformation numérique mais qu'il faut
et qu'il faudra mettre à l'agenda à bref
délai donc cassiopée nous sommes en
train également d'y travailler et
cassiopée donne également d'excellents
résultats
même s'il ya ces difficultés sur
lesquels d'abord nous nous nous
travaillons et nous avons parfaitement
conscience des difficultés qu'ils ont pu
s'opposer mais je me permets de parler
au passé moi sur ces questions et enfin
sur l'âge unip alors sur l'âge unique
bon là j'ai dit moi je l'avais pas
initier la génisse j'ai hérité de ce
bébé si j'ose dire je me suis rendu
compte que d'abord c'était très éloigné
de mes préoccupations de proximité que
sur le plan budgétaire
[Musique]
il fallait qu'on embauche beaucoup de
monde que ça coûterait bien plus cher
que ce que nous avions imaginé et par
ailleurs le numérique permet de pallier
les difficultés il est en fonctionnement
de la jupe
donc on estime que l'âge unip voilà être
loin de notre réalité pour la conserver
ne pas rentrer dans le détail de la
dématérialisation du du contentieux en
l'espèce mais le choix de centraliser en
une juridiction unique la procédure
rapide de traitement de l'impayé nous
semble dans ce contexte économique
difficile
assez peu compatible au fond et que
l'objectif du gouvernement qui est de
renforcer une justice proche du
justiciable
qu'ils soient créanciers au débiteur
voilà pourquoi la jenny peu n'est plus
madame la sénatrice à l'ordre du jour
ainsi monsieur le garde madame la
ministre souhaitait répondre puis après
je verrai la parole à mâcher thani
mohamed soilihi monsieur richard alors
c'est très chaud à très court pour
remercier monsieur le garde des sceaux
de l'information qui m'a donnée
concernant la commission d'harmonisation
du droit local mais monsieur le garde
des sceaux ma question portait sur la
numérisation du registre des
associations alors on n'est pas obligé
de me répondre bah non c'est très
technique mais si vous pouviez me faire
donner une réponse ce sera la commission
ce sont bien deux choses différentes
madame la musique j'avais la parole mais
chez le président moi y avait trois
points sur lesquels au vu des questions
je voulais revenir d'abord sur
l'ergonomie des applicatifs métiers pour
les agents
là je vous parle de l'ensemble des
applicatifs métiers de l'ensemble des
agents publics et d'une stratégie comme
jour il dit c'est de dire dans le plan
de relance 200 millions d'euros pour les
outils des agents 200 millions d'euros
pour les démarches numérique je vais
revenir et 80 du coût pour les
collectivités
à chaque fois que dans le plan de
relance dans les différents crédits
mon ministère avec l'ensemble des
ministères appui soutien finances nous
testons les applicatifs métiers avec les
agents et nous sommes passés dans
l'ensemble la transformation de l'état
dans une logique d'amélioration continue
c'est une rupture totale parce que vous
savez comment je faisais avant
d'ailleurs le mystère la justice dans le
temps d'avant a quand même vu beaucoup
de procédures
signe que les charges ont laissé des
gens travaillent pendant sept ans
revenait le bébé et on nous dévoile ait
délivré
[Musique]